- Danny, what did you do?!
- Oh, God, they think we're killin' it.
- We're not contenders.
Do they really expect me to figure it all out in one season?
- If you're a contender, you can't live in this building.
- We're being set up...by someone we know.
An overly quirky collection of oddballs, losers...
...and whatever the f--k the Seahawks are.
Do we really know any of them?
And why am I podcasting so much?
- That's sneaky interesting. Coming up next on the Bill Sim—
- With our schedule, we've just been taking out the garbage.
- I already spoke to the authorities. We didn't do anything wrong.
- Sounds like someone spread a nasty little rumor about me...again.
- They had to be close to us...someone in our division.
- Hey, sorry, still here. Do you guys know how to get ahh!
- So it's either the Cowboys or the Eagles.
- It was me! We're contenders!
- He's an old man. He doesn't know what he's saying!
- I'm just humble Jalen Hurts, man.
- Are you? Just think about it.
Jalen...Hurts!
- Oh!
- It's in his name.
- Hurts people hurt people.
- Fine! Sure, I hid it in college.
But the truth is, I'm a stone-cold killer!
Arrest me.
- What? What, no, man. You just have to go live with the good teams.
- It's been too long. Let's catch up!
-Comin' up, we'll talk to my buddy Doink about whether the Giants...
...would be better off with a Back like Rex Burkhead.
I'm telling you:
Celery is the nobody-believes-in-us vegetable of crudités.
Brian Hoyer: Ewing Theory candidate?
Is Shaggy from Scooby-Doo the Cordarrelle Patterson of Hanna-Barbera?